Năm 5, chúng ta điều giữa thứ biên ngày ăn đã tiếp nhận hàng lỡ thứ biên bệnh.
Huyện chúng ta đang khoảng lỡi, lưỡi giữa thứ biên tốt chế độ chính xác đối với tảm i bà thứ biên bệnh bệnh.
Mì tảm thân nhân người có công và năm cán bộ lỡi mất sức của 2 tình ngày ăn là hả tính.
Gặp lỡ, thâm hỏi sức hỏa đợi việc tinh thần, chào qua các thứ biên bệnh bệnh bệnh và thân nhân lệ sĩ.
Thay mặt lãnh đạo đàn nhắn nước và vui tình cảm cá nhân.
Đồng chi trên cầm tủ người lời triển sâu sắc của những tình cảm trên sọng nhất đến các nổ chi thương biên.
Mệnh bệnh đang lực trăm sốc, nuôi giữa nếu chỉ tại chúng tâm và tòn thề cảm bộ,
viên trước người ló đầu chúng tâm lời trọt thân ai và những tình cảm thân thiết.
Thường chực bán biệt thương nhận mạnh, đang nhắn nước và nhân dân ta lời đời đời viên dành,
chiến công hơn, sự hiến sĩnh của cảnh hùng lỡ sĩ, thương biên bệnh.
Thấm nhận sâu sắc đạo lỡi, chuyển thống tốt đẹp của rất tộc.
Và lời dạy của chúng tịch của chi Minh, bệnh miệnh chiến năm qua đang nhắn nước,
luôn đặc biệt quan tâm, trong lò, tui diện tốt công tác đến ơn đáp nghiệm.
Lối với những người có công với các mạng và các gia đình chính xác.
Thương chực bán biệt thương đình nghiệm an với hợp với bộ nơi vụ.
Phan thiển các thủ tục để suy tôn để sĩ cho các đồng chi ý đạo thư trần.
Thì xây thị hưởng tình cảm, chắc nhận và sự chiến sâu sắc với những cầu viên,
khi xin thầm lặng của các đồng chi, nhận dịt này, thay mặt lãnh đạo đạn nhắn nước,
thương chực bán biệt thương viên, đều dương cấp ý chính quyền các tốt tình nghiệm an và chung tâm
đã có nhiều cố gắng thực hiện tốt chế độ chính xác trong lò đối với người có công,
cảm ơn đổi mù cán bộ nhân viên người ló đổng chung tâm đã luôn nỗ lực,
tận tâm, chắc nhận, chăm sóc tận đầy, chú đáo các thương biên bệnh.
Thì đó, thương chực bán biệt thương và đàn công tác chung viên đã thành phính dân quan,
rất hương tự nhiệm chú tịch hồ chí mình, tại khu dịch thức ra đặt biệt kiếm liên tình nghiệm an.
Chức lúc bị ra người vẫn khu quên để lại những lời cân dẫn trong bản dưới chút lịch sử cho tọn đàn,
tọn quân, tọn dất tác. Ngay sau khi cuộc chống Mỹ cứ lước của những dân tác đã hoàn toàn tháng lợi.
Công việc đầu tiên đối với con người, là chăm lo cho thương biên và những người có công trong sự nghiệp lại phóng rất tộc.
Thống nhất rất nước. Nhân dịp chỉ nghiệp bệnh miếng sáo năm ngày chuyên thống lực lượng tháng liên xung phong.
Mấy lắm tháng bệnh năm 1815, mấy lắm tháng 17 năm, hành hình của trong hệ sáo,
năm 1815 trên tháng đổ lực và năm 1815 ngày hình xin của người lưới tháng liên xung phong tại khu dịch gà mà đổ lực.
Đồng chỉ thường trực ban biệt thư trên thẩm tụi và đoàn thuốc tác, đã thành kiến giấn vòng qua,
rất hương tại nhà tưởng liệm tháng liên xung phong vàng quốc. Đây là nơi gây hơn 1 nghiên liên xí yên tháng liên xung phong trong cả nước.
Rân hương, rất qua tại khu mộn mời nữ anh hùng lệ xí tháng liên xung phong, khi xin tại nhà mà đổ lực.